He is strong with the force but he will
not be safe until he masters his abilities
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going
to be my new luke skywalker mandalorian season
2 finale video it was probably one of the biggest
surprises i never expected them to go for that big
of a reference or that big of an original trilogy
character so we'll explain what's going on with
luke skywalker in the timeline right now and what
they're going to be doing with him in the future
what this means now that he's a big mandalorian
character if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos i'll be doing
mandalorian season 3 videos while we wait for
season 3 to get here and all the spin-offs series
i've got links in my description for a lot of
those i've already done videos for some of them
probably one of the coolest needle drop moments
though was luke skywalker's darth vader rogue one
hallways scene papa blessed they went full darth
vader with luke skywalker it's just that in this
context he's not killing a bunch of rebels he's
actually getting rid of a bunch of dark troopers
that are trying to kill the protagonists the
people that we want to survive when jon favreau
was talking about them doing the luke skywalker
cameo scene them actually filming it they said
they brought mark hamill down to the set now they
didn't film him in motion capture they got another
actor to body double for a younger version of luke
but mark hamill did all the original dialogue
and they tried to get as much information and
data from him to make their version of luke make
the de-aging process look as authentic as possible
i think they did a better job than they did with
the version of leia during rogue one like the
technology is getting a little bit better every
single year so we'll talk about what this means
for future luke and other characters that they
might try to do this with in future seasons one
of the bigger questions that a lot of people had
is why didn't luke skywalker sense grogos sooner
if he's been around for this entire time since
the prequels and for those of you asking why mando
didn't ask for luke skywalker's name like he never
says it and he doesn't know who luke skywalker is
the reason for that is because he was just
giving grogu to the jedi and he's trusting him
with this look here like i see that you're a good
person you said that you would die for him so i'm
trusting you eventually he will probably learn who
luke skywalker is someone will tell him because
not everybody is just completely clueless about
this kind of stuff it just they want to let you
know that in the outer rim out here most people
are just concerned with their own lives in their
own small sphere of the galaxy they're not really
getting the news day-to-day from the other side
of the galaxy or even the core worlds of the
new republic so that's why he would know about
the death star being blown up but he wouldn't know
necessarily who luke skywalker was or that he was
darth vader's son or about emperor palpatine being
a sith lord the other real big easter egg here too
is r2d2 they have a bit of a funny meeting
it's just meant to cut the tension of the
moment because it's getting so serious and so sad
everyone's crying so much the thing about r2d2 is
that he used to belong to anakin skywalker and
knew anakin through his entire childhood so he
spent a lot of time at the jedi temple grogu is
about the same age was born about the same year as
anakin skywalker so r2 would have been at the jedi
temple when grogu was there and probably remembers
him a long time ago george lucas said that r2d2
was the only one who didn't have his memory wiped
and thus because he hadn't been killed off was one
of the only characters who had any memories of the
prequels of that true story of anakin skywalker
now we have ahsoka tano on the series and she
knew anakin very well she's alive and present day
she could tell stories but she didn't know anakin
when he was a child like r2 did and because of
this a lot of people are also theorizing now
that it was actually r2d2 that saved grogu's life
at the jedi temple and took him away it's just a
theory but it's just a really cool twist that
makes sense of a lot of these moments here but
in terms of where luke skywalker is how powerful
he is and why it took him so long to find grogu
there's only a little bit of story between the
events of return of the jedi and right now on
the mandalorian for luke skywalker that's still
technically canon now you have to imagine that
john favreau and dave filoni are pulling a bunch
of easter eggs and references from legends like
grand admiral thrawn is a really good example
they'll continue to do that and i do think there
are a couple other big easter eggs from the
legends that i think that they'll try to bring
back because of what's happening during this era
of the timeline but the biggest thing that happens
to luke right after return of the jedi is that
he starts to train leia in the force she gets
far enough through her jedi training to construct
her own lightsaber but because she's pregnant with
kylo ren or ben solo whatever you want to call
him she starts getting these anakin skywalker-like
force visions that tell her that something bad
might happen to ben if she continues down the
path of the force so she quits her training then
goes back to be more active political figure in
the new republic as it's still in the process of
forming and to be a mother to ben they kind of
addressed the new republic during the mandalorian
season 2 the current state of affairs most of the
outer rim territories don't think that the new
republic cares about them or believes that the
empire is back which is why grand admiral thrawn
is able to build his forces up so much and wreak
off his chaos also remember that mando and bill
burst mayfield character get the whole grand plan
from his former commander before he shoots him on
the spot how grand admiral thrawn and moff gideon
have this plan to create so much chaos around
the galaxy the new republic won't be able to help
everyone and one by one the systems in all the
major sectors will start crying out for a return
to order begging the empire to come back and fix
things it's a very insidious plan and it sounds
like it came straight from grand admiral thrawn
he's a more calculating cold sherlockian villain
most of his plots involve getting people or
organizations like the rebellion and now the new
republic to tear themselves apart saving him the
trouble then you have the battle of jakku which is
the true end of the empire where they have another
civil war there's a coup and some of the admirals
take what's left of their fleet and jump them
into the unknown regions to become the first order
then at some point after that grand admiral thrawn
resurfaces we still haven't seen him yet but it's
around this period that he starts to resurface in
the outer rim then just a little while before the
events of the mandalorian series luke goes on a
new quest to search for all the remaining jedi
texts around the galaxy that the emperor didn't
have destroyed that's where he starts working with
lor san tekka's character in the church of the
force they reference their group a little bit more
during rogue one they're kind of like the clergy
they worship the force itself the midichlorians
and they're kind of like helpers and aids to the
jedi keepers of knowledge and they maintain all
the jedi temples then about six years after the
battle of endor he continues to search the galaxy
for potential jedi students so that he can create
a new jedi temple of his own and it's during this
period that he hears grogu calling out through
the force and once he senses him from across the
galaxy he's able to continue tracking him through
the force to moff gideon's ship answering the real
question though why did it take this long for him
to find grogu the reason why he couldn't sense him
before now is because as ahsoka tano said after
order 66 grogu's memory goes dark he kind of
loses his memory he started hiding his abilities
in order to survive hiding himself from the force
even though he seems like a child he was smart
enough to know that being a jedi put him in danger
he is pretty powerful but as luke skywalker
says talent without training is nothing moff
gideon also references grogu's limitations you're
pretty good at that as it uses forced telekinesis
to throw the stormtroopers around and force choke
them but he can only sustain that level of output
for short bursts and it just completely drains him
so luke skywalker shows up to rescue everyone from
the dark troopers thus the title of the episode
aka the rescue mando was rescuing grogu but the
larger reference was for luke skywalker coming
at the end a lot of you also made the joke that
the title the rescue is also a reference to
jon favreau and dave filoni rescuing star wars
but at this point in the timeline luke is only
about 28 years old he's still super young in the
flashbacks that we've seen before in the movies
he's in his 40s way way older this is also why
he's dressed very similar to the way he dressed
in return of the jedi because when john favreau
was doing interviews about the luke cameo he kept
talking about return of the jedi like it was so
much fun watching that movie now i actually get
to tell the story of what happens right after that
so that's basically what they're doing what
happened to luke right after return of the jedi
and this idea is really important for all the
new luke skywalker story that jon favreau dave
filoni write for future mandalorian episodes and
any other places that luke shows up on the other
tv shows like the ahsoka tano series the only
canonical story right now for what happens to luke
in the next several years is that he creates his
school within a few years of kylo ren coming to
train there and that doesn't happen until six
years after he rescues grogu on moff gideon ship
that's a long time six whole years for them to
play with luke skywalker without even bumping
up against any of the other story so they can do
pretty much anything they want to with luke during
this period the only other things that we know
about him during this era is that he was searching
the galaxy for other jedi to train and that's
about it so right now as they leave mando and the
others they're going to a new republic controlled
safe world that's strong in the force to train
grogu really good example that would be yavin 4
because of all the ancient jedi temples there it's
a place that's naturally very attuned to the force
and if you didn't read the legends books there was
this whole jedi academy series about luke's jedi
academy he created it on yavin 4 because all those
rebel bases that we saw during the original
trilogy and during rogue one were former jedi
temples from thousands of years ago during the old
republic era since they go for so many original
trilogy references i would not be surprised if jon
favreau and dave filoni tried to include that kind
of easter egg because yavin 4 is also very close
to being the swamp-like environment that yoda's
species thrives in and grogu would thrive in then
they start their training montage but because
they're still keeping grogu on the mandalorian
series and most of season 3 will be mando helping
Bo Katan the other mandalorians dealing with
everything that's happening with the dark saber
and the fact that he's technically the new man the
lore now the new leader of their people by rights
eventually they'll have to find a reason for
grogu to return to mando and since they're
so big on referencing original trilogy moments
you'll remember something similar happened to
luke skywalker when he went to train with yoda on
dagobah he left before his training was complete
because he started getting forced visions of han
and leia in danger ahsoka tano referenced yoda
saying that i've only seen one other of his kind
press f to pay respects to yattle because either
she just forgot about her or they didn't want to
reference her at all but the reason why yoda has
not appeared to grogu is because he knew that luke
skywalker would find him eventually and train him
the story will all take place during this part
of the timeline and it'll all be stuff that
jon favreau and dave filoni create themselves but
hopefully that explains what's going on with luke
skywalker in this part of the timeline i think the
idea is is they won't bring him back very often
when they do they want it to be for very very big
moments but obviously grand admiral thrawn is such
a big villain that luke will also probably get
pulled into this big thrawn plot and he's just
the beginning there are plenty of other force
sensitives and jedi characters that are still
alive at this point in the timeline that they
can introduce on the shows and i haven't heard
any rumors about this yet but luke skywalker
canonically at least up to this point never met
ahsoka he learned about her later in his life but
i hope that jon favreau and dave filoni just sort
of sidestepped that and they eventually have luke
skywalker show up on the ahsoka tano series so he
can help her and they can talk about his father
anakin skywalker because she has so many stories
that she could tell him and at this point in the
timeline she does not know about luke and leia but
let me know in the comments what do you want them
to do with luke skywalker in the future of the
mandalorian spin-off series do you actually want
to see that ahsoka tano luke skywalker scene i
feel like that would be the next really big needle
drop moment they could pull in another season or 2
i've got a couple other mandalorian videos that
i'm working on but leave all your requests in
the comments below everyone click here to watch
john favreau himself break down that new book
of boba fett teaser for the mandalorian spin-off
series and click here for my brand new mandalorian
season 3 top 10 video thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe this is the way!